الى التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
احباط هجوم اوكراني وتدمير 11د عش طائره
مسيره في اجواء مقاطعتي كالوجا وكورس
الروسيتين في الساعات الماضيه ولم تذكر
الوزاره تفاصيل بشان الخسائر الماديه
نتيجه هذا
الهجوم وعلى الجانب الاوكراني اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني سقوط ثلاثه قتلى وخمسه جرحى في
قصف روسي استهدف مدينه خيرسون جنوبي
البلاد واضاف ان هجمات روسيه استهدفت 100
بلده في الساعات ال 24ش الماضيه في
مقاطعات تشيرنيهيف وسومي
وخاركوف
بورجيا وخير سون واشار الجيش الاوكراني
الى انه خاض اكثر من 20 اشتباكا مع القوات
الروسيه كما اكد انه يواصل عملياته باتجاه
باخم اما على المحور الجنوبي زابروجيا
فقال الجيش الاوكراني ان عملياته باتجاه
مدينه
ملتبل لا تزال
متواصله ومعنا من زبروجيا مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام غارات روسيه اذا في مناطق شتى
غارات كثيفه و2
اشتباكا يقول الجيش
الاوكراني ما الصوره التي ترسمها هذه
الاشتباكات وهذا القصف لما يجري على الجبه
[موسيقى]
الان وبالفعل الان صافرات الانذار تدوي في
عموم البلاد كافه بعد ان رصدت الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه اي وجود طائرات من من
طراز ميك 31 كي الروسيه القادره على حمل
صواريخ فرد صوتيه وعندما يتم رصد مثل هذه
الطائرات في الاجواء فانه يتم تفعيل
صافرات الانذار في كافه انحاء البلاد على
اعتبار ان هذه الطائرات الاستراتيجيه
بامكانها ان تقصف وتوجه صواريخها الفرد
صوتيه الى اي مكان على ايه حال نحن ننتظر
ربما وجود اي تطورات بهذا الخصوص على صعيد
اخر الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
في تصريحه المسائي قال بان على
الاوكرانيين ان ينتظروا اخبارا ساره كما
قال يوم الغد وهذا يتعلق كما يقول بتعزيز
قوه الدوله بتعزيز مكانه ال الجيش والامه
بحسب تعبيره ولم يفصح على كثير من
المعلومات في هذا السياق لكن هنالك من
يرجح بان هذه الانباء الساره التي يتحدث
عنها زيلنسكي ربما تكون تتعلق بتقدم ما
على احدى جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا او اما
انها تتعلق في عقد صفقات جديده من شانها
ان تعزز
القدرات العسكريه سواء كانت الهجوميه او
الدفاعيه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا لا سما وان
كيف العاصمه تستضيف في هذه الايام منتدى
للدفاعات ال الدفاعات العسكريه بمشاركه
اكثر من 120 شركه رائده في هذا المجال من
حول العالم على الصعيدي نفسه هنا في محور
زبروجيا جنوبا الجيش الاوكراني ما زال
يقول بانه يواجه قتالا شرسا مع القوات
الروسيه في محور
راوتينيكس الاوكراني قد تعثر قليلا في هذا
المحور على اعتبار انه ما زال يراوح مكانه
منذ اسابيع عده لا سما عند را بوتين الذي
قال بالامس بانه صدى هجوما للقوات الروسيه
التي حاولت استعاده معاقلها وتحصيناتها
التي فقدها وهذا يعني بان القوات الروسيه
ايضا ما زالت تعمل من اجل دفع وصد هذا
الهجوم المعاكس الذي تقوم به القوات
الاوكرانيه في هذا المحور تحديدا محور اخر
ملتهب حقيقه هو خرسون حيث تقول بعض
التقديرات العسكريه